ce qui me traitaient grande s'il doit me
pose est est-ce qu'il leur faudra encore
non de plus calme une fois plus depuis
l'aspect riant
je savais pas ça
si je crois que c'est quand même
important que j'ai fait mais je savais
pas quel point qui allait avoir des
répercussions je pense métier moi car
j'étais petit j'avais paul de ses
reportages là j'avais pas être écoutés
depuis l'été passé quand je t'ai
reparler de ça j'étais sarti encore
affectés ouais mais les une moto en ce
moment mais je crois que c'est plus le
fait que tout le monde l'ait vu oui
c'est toute ma famille le petit je m'en
fait encore parler de style reportage le
risque de l'avoir dit des fois oui
ouais mais la leçon de discrimination
qui règlent tout et pour tout le monde
et a nié tout danse prend la main il n'y
a pas de conflit après c'est parce que
vous avez vécu on le vécu un certain
mais ton vieille maman de chance tu
rencontres d'autres gens qui voient
d'autres personnes bientôt des valeurs
de belleval ans qui transforme qui sait
sa fonction qui est oublié cette façon
qu'est ce qui était resté toit ce qui
était resté quelque chose de cette
expérience là oui je crois que oui je
crois que ça a changé ma vision des
choses
je veux vraiment avoir les jambes je
suis quelqu'un d'assez ceux ci
apprennent en sol donc exposé paul
apparent souvient qu'ils vont arrêter et
die par la question la main